it really showcases homer's heart and as
the show progresses and it becomes a lot
more
wackier and there's a lot more
buffoonery sometimes homer's heart gets
lost in the noise
hello i'm jack mccone host of worst
episode ever a simpsons podcast
and we are going to talk about every job
homer has ever had in the simpsons
[Music]
we're gonna define these jobs as
anything homer's done paid or unpaid
ranging from his main job at the nuclear
power plant to any of the many
one-off gags off-screen references and
whatnot over the course of 31 seasons
and counting
[Music]
[Applause]
this is the very first episode of the
show way back in 1989.
homer is a nuclear technician here he
works on the floor handling
inanimate radioactive rods and while he
only has this for the first two or three
episodes out of
nearly 700 we actually still see him
each week doing this in the opening
theme song when he bounces the green rod
and the simpsons started out as a very
grounded portrayal of a working-class
blue-collar family
so it made sense for homer to start out
literally on the floor of a factory
it could have been a nuclear power plant
it could have been a ford car assembly
line it could have really been any
industrial american job the way it
looked you knew right off the bat oh
this is the type of guy he is this is
the type of family he has
and in this episode simpson's roasting
on an open fire mr burns actually
removes the christmas bonuses he takes
away everybody's bonuses and because
this is a very grounded realistic
working-class family
homer actually doesn't have any money to
buy christmas presents for his kids
so he's forced to take on a second job
and because this is a christmas special
homer gets a gig as a mall santa claus
hey santa what's shakin man what's your
name partner
now what's very interesting about homer
as a mall santa is this is already
the first second job we see homer get as
you'll see a lot of these jobs homer has
in addition to his original job
and we're seeing this kind of american
iconic job the mall santa and they pull
the curtain back
in their very funny subversive way where
we can kind of see
the inner workings of how this works the
training class and this is starting a
pattern that we'll see for the rest of
the series where we don't just get the
job we get the behind the scenes look at
the job
and remember this is the very first
episode and the show its initial roots
was a subversive
but realistic look at american life this
is they're still existing in our reality
now by episode 700
season 31 homer might actually become
santa claus it hasn't happened yet but
it might happen
but here it's just a very realistic look
at a working-class guy in a suit with a
fake beard
so this is only the third episode in the
series and already homer gets fired from
his job as a nuclear technician and this
is when he decides
at this crossroads in his life to devote
himself to helping other people starting
with a stop sign of an intersection and
that snowballs into him going around
town
just trying to help people and keep them
safe a lot of the jobs he does
highlights exactly what kind of man
homer simpson is and the safety crusade
might really get to the core of who a
homer is just three episodes in
and then he targets the biggest threat
to springfield safety and that's the
nuclear power plant he goes after mr
burns and uh he does such a good job
that mr burns has no choice but to
actually
hire homer as a safety inspector time's
up
what the hey i'll take the job excellent
and this is where homer gets the job
that he still has to this
day his day job as a safety inspector
for sector 7g
with the very famous console
when homer gets a full head of hair he
actually gets promoted by mr burns from
safety inspector to
a high level executive he gets access to
the executive bathroom
he gets his own assistant and this kind
of showcases now we're only in season
two and he's already had three different
positions at the power plant and that
number will grow he'll basically have
every position at the plant now season
one thirteen episodes they already did a
very well-rounded job of poking fun
at working-class life what they're
already starting to do here in season
two
is poke fun at the higher levels of
capitalism so he gets the job because he
has a full out of hair
which shows the superficiality of kind
of the corporate
executive environment
so many of homer's jobs that we're going
to cover he has a rise and fall arc
and this might actually be the first so
he tells this entire story through a
flashback at most and you see him become
a mascot for this minor league baseball
team dance and homer where he just has a
cape and a t-shirt
and he rises becomes a huge celebrity
he's transferred to
capital city to play for the majors i
just got the word
you've been called up to capital city
and he quickly falls he's no longer
a big fish in the small pond and he ends
up back at moe's
telling the story to the local bar flies
[Music]
after finding out he has a long-lost
half-brother in detroit who runs this
multi-million dollar car company
homer's offered the chance to design his
own car i want you
to help me design a car
a car for all the homer simpsons out
there he designs the homer this 80
thousand dollar monstrosity
that has a bunch of ridiculous ideas
that ends up costing his brother his
entire company and by this point the
series even though it's
early on they've already established
homer as pretty much a buffoon
an idiot so this is one of many cases
where homer bites off more than he can
chew
now season three this is the beginning
of the classic era of simpsons and this
is where homer
picking up a second job on top of his
existing job really starts to ramp up
in this case he's getting a second job
to pay for lisa's happiness he
buys her a pony in a stable and he has
to work two jobs with very little room
for sleep in between
pink hat when i ordered that blueberry
squishy i meant today
coming right up sir and this job is a
classic example of homer just having a
huge heart the sacrifices he makes for
his family
in this case for lisa he's not just
getting a second job he's basically
working 24 hours a day
and nearly getting himself killed
falling asleep at the wheel and this
just shows homer
for all those faults he loves his family
more than anything
emo you got any cough syrup uh let me
check the lost and found
so homer shows a knack for inventing
throughout the series and it probably
begins here when he designs his own
cocktail the flaming moe
just using things in his kitchen the
secret ingredient is children's cough
syrup
homer you turn the blades too fast so a
lot of homer's jobs
aren't actually concurrent with his time
at the power plant we see them in
flashback form
i married marge takes place in 1980 and
homer is working on a mini golf course
when they conceive bart in a windmill on
one of the holes
maybe it's the champale talking but
i think you're pretty sexy really
it must be the champal talking and after
they conceive bart and they need to get
married
homer takes on a bunch of other jobs to
help pay the bills this includes being a
trainer at the pitless pup attack dog
school
a candle maker at the ye old candle
maker shop knife salesman for slash co
and an employee at the gulpin blow he
works a drive-through and this is
actually where he
re-proposes to marge using an onion ring
as an engagement ring
[Music]
now this is one of the more famous
episodes of the simpsons early years
and while it's a work league and it's
not exactly a
paid job because homer is playing along
baseball greats like daryl strawberry
and ken griffey jr
we're gonna go ahead and consider this a
job now homer at the bat is uh
is a very important episode in the
series because it might be the first
that has a slew of celebrity guest stars
as themselves and this is something
that's gonna happen a lot more as we go
on
these guys aren't so tough i've got
wonder bet
[Music]
this kind of changes the nature not only
of the show but
of homer's relationship to the real
world most of us don't get to play
baseball with daryl strawberry but
homer's going to end up playing a lot of
different sports with a lot of different
famous athletes
after discovering a beautiful and
talented country singer named lily
lumpkin
homer actually signs on to be her
manager slash
agent uh making her famous overnight i
want you to be my manager
really homer gives up the sweet gig
after realizing that it might cost him
his marriage with march
and this is one of many cases where
homer has to choose between his job and
his family sometimes he gets a job that
he truly loves doing
but it's gonna cost him his family and
at the end of the day homer always goes
with his family
up until now nearly every job homer has
had is within the realm of possibilities
for the character of homer simpson
even when he's dancing homer he's
basically just getting drunk and
dancing in front of a bunch of people
this showcases a skill set
that is kind of turning homer into this
renaissance man savant
we didn't know up until this point that
he could be a country music manager
and we'll start to see this more and
more where homer's doing a job you would
have never expected him to do in season
one
[Music]
homer finds local success as a plow
truck driver when he crashes both of his
cars and needs to buy a new vehicle he
ends up buying a plow truck
and tries to make his money back by
plowing the streets of springfield until
he loses his job to his best friend
barney and to god
mr plow is interesting because this is
the first time homer really starts his
own small business
as opposed to getting a job somewhere
else or being a manager
and this is the american dream to open
up your own small business
homer tries out and is arbitrarily
selected to be the conductor for
springfield's new monorail
well i've been monitoring your progress
closely but
this gentleman here clearly stands out
above the rest who me
yeah sure and this is interesting
because this is one of the first
big epic plots where springfield is in
danger and homer actually saves a day
by anchoring the monorail before it runs
off track
doughnuts is there anything they can't
do
hey what did this job pay union leader
this is interesting because it actually
ties way back into homer's odyssey
where homer wants to protect his fellow
workers and fellow townspeople
as safety inspector and in this case
he's trying to protect their dental plan
and i don't know what gets more american
than trying to protect your dental plan
and this is considered one of the
all-time best episodes of the show
not only because there's maybe a joke
every four seconds why must you turn my
office into a house of lies
but it's a david versus goliath story
it's homer taking on mr burns
just like he did in homer's odyssey but
now the show is really firing on all
cylinders this is season four
the characters are really defined and
homer steps up not just for himself but
selflessly for the other townspeople
this is another 15 minutes of fame
episode and this was the season five
premiere
and this is really taking it to the nth
degree homer literally becomes bigger
than jesus
bigger than the beatles what'd you do
screw up like the beatles and say you
were bigger than jesus
all the time it was the title of our
second album
we've seen homer care about other people
and we've seen
him start to invent things and be
creative but he also has this knack for
artistry and entertaining when it comes
to acting and especially when it comes
to music this is not the first band
homer will be a part of
that becomes internationally famous and
season five is where the show really
starts taking off with these
larger-than-life plots we start to break
out of springfield and homer's
internationally famous he's not just a
mall santa
he's famous around the world he even
wins a grammy 21
do that card counting thing again homer
becomes a well-liked blackjack dealer at
mr burns casino
mainly because he's not very good at it
and everybody wins
[Music]
homer leads a vigilante group when a cat
burglar starts striking around town
and this is interesting because it kind
of ties into this larger american
machismo archetype homer needs to go
around and bust heads but it's also
it ties into his character because he's
very protective of his family
when lisa gets his saxophone stolen it
really shakes him and this is why he
ends up forming a vigilante group
hello everybody i'm archie bell and i'm
also the drones bart gets famous but uh
we seen a flashback that one of his very
first jobs was a street musician
and this ties into what we were saying
about the b sharps homer does have this
innate musical talent
he's been in multiple bands and in this
case he's the entire band
a lot of earlier fans thought deep space
homer was when the show
really just broke away from what it used
to be are we there yet i'm thirsty
ugh mission control requests permission
to sedate cargo ahead of schedule
homer is sent to space as a
working-class astronaut to boost nasa
ratings and
ends up averting disasters he almost
crashes a space shuttle that has buzz
aldrin in it it's a
very funny classic episode but the idea
of homer simpson going to space is
something that would have seemed
ridiculous in season one and matt
groening
the creator of the simpsons talks about
a rubber band reality how far
the show can actually stretch the
reality of the simpsons and at this
point in season five they really wanted
to see if they could get away with
sending homer to space
and as we'll see by season 31 the rubber
band could actually be stretched a lot
farther than that
but what makes this episode work is that
while the setting is kind of ridiculous
and they are stretching that rubber band
literally to outer orbit homer is still
the same character we know from season
one season two season three we're just
seeing him in this other set of
ridiculous circumstances
homer serves on a jury for freddie
quimby's murder trial and he's actually
the only one of the 12
that wants to vote to acquit him mainly
because of all the
deluxe accommodations you get when
you're sequestered uh are the rest of
you voting
guilty okay fine how many s's and
innocent
homer gets a job at the adult education
addicts giving tips on
a successful marriage which is ironic
because a job basically devolves into
him gossiping about marge and almost
ends of divorce
now this is a story line where homer's
selfishness not as selflessness
it drives the plot and you know homer
can sometimes be a real jerk
that's kind of why we love him but this
one really really tests
just how far can homer go without
breaking his marriage which is
one of the core spines of the show
[Music]
after finding a truckload of raw sugar
as one does homer tries to profit by
selling it as much as he can
even door-to-door this is one of many
get-rich-quick schemes that we're going
to start to see as the show moves on
if taking on a second job or a night job
is a facet of america that the show
likes to cover so is the get rich quick
scheme
first you get the sugar then you'll get
the
power then you'll get the women
what's the matter with you homer we
don't have any fruits or vegetables in
the car
the whole truck's full of a marsh on
their long drive to itchy and scratchy
land
homer gets pulled over and caught
smuggling illegally presumably
some fruits and vegetables this is
interesting because not only is it the
first time homer's gonna smuggle
something but it's also the first time
he's really doing anything illicit and
we'll see
a handful of the jobs we're gonna cover
are either
gray market or black market gigs
homer and grandpa become old-school
traveling salesman for a tonic that
grandpa devises that is uh it's
basically a forerunner for viagra
i'm gonna make it after uh
this is a dream job of homer's but he
only holds it briefly he leaves the
nuclear power
plant once the family is financially
sound but when maggie is conceived and
they're going to have a third child
homer again sacrifices for his family by
giving up his dream job to go work back
at the power plant a homer will always
choose his family over his own happiness
and because homer actually quits the
power plant and
is forced to beg for his job back mr
burns cruelly makes him put up this sign
don't forget you're here forever and
in one of the most heartwarming moments
in the series history homer
covers that sign up with pictures of
maggie so that the only letters left
spell
do it for her and if that's not america
for you working to put food on your
family's table
i don't know what is that that is the
simpsons
convinced by a new billboard to go to
clown college homer becomes a crusty
impersonator
until the mob almost kills him because
they think he's the real deal i'm seeing
double here
four krusty's to make up for a debt to
his hated sister-in-law's homer needs
another second job and in this case he
becomes a chauffeur for
classy joe's one of his clients is mel
brooks it's very funny hey
let's do that 2000 pound man thing i'll
be that carl reiner guy and you'll be
what's his face but
the ball destroyed homer is put on the
jury for springfield's first film
festival
and becomes the deciding vote between
barney's art house masterpiece and mr
burns's bombastic ego trip
as well as hans mohlman's football in
the groin astarz burns is uh it's one of
my favorite episodes it's actually a
crossover with another brilliant
animated show the critic
starring john lovitz as jay sherman now
while i love this episode matt greening
was actually against it from the very
start and still isn't crazy about it
because he thought doing a crossover
with another show
was beneath the simpsons and this was
the first time the simpsons really had
ever done that
and if you ever want to visit my show
nah we're not going to be doing that
but like other far-fetched plots that
the show has done if they can do it
funny
and they can do it true to the
characters why not
this is one of those quick gags blinking
you missed it but basically homer
invites his old sergeant to dinner and
when the dinner party is ruined by all
the new puppies that the simpsons have
homer's basically recalled back into the
army
samsung see you at riverly oh 500
tomorrow
and this is really the first time it's
implied homer ever had a any background
in the armed forces but as we'll see
uh it's not the last
head of a detective agency this one's
not really shown but it's mentioned by
marge it's a quick one-off gag
your father can be surprisingly
sensitive remember when i giggled at a
sherlock holmes hat
he soaked for a week and then closed his
detective agency hear ye
hear ye the homer broadcasting system
is on the air this one kind of starts
off as a joke because uh homer's perfect
for a town crier he's loud he's
boisterous but it ends up tying
very neatly into the plot when he uses
his gig to help lisa
expose the town's history did you get
that report on the accounting department
when smithers finally goes on vacation
he picks homer to take his job
basically because homer's the last
person he would ever expect mr burns to
like more than him
i told you i don't like ethnic food so
homer actually gets his job because he's
the most incompetent employee
at the power plant smithers basically
doesn't want anybody to outshine him at
his own job
and homer does do such a bad job that mr
burns actually becomes self-sufficient
[Music]
homer's knack for taking cannonballs to
the gut gets him a job as a freak
at hullabalooza which is a big 90s
festival that has smashing pumpkins and
cypress hill
it's one of these second job plots where
homer briefly becomes famous and it's
tied into his love for
the entertainment industry and it
basically comes down to it's literally
killing him and he has to quit
before it does this episode's
interesting because it starts off
grounded homer gets this
job that's not too dissimilar from his
own basically he's headhunted because
he's the most senior member at the power
plant but it gradually turns into this
ridiculous james bond spectacle his boss
is literally a super villain named hank
scorpio
who takes over the east coast by the end
of the episode and we're seeing it from
homer's perspective where
he's clueless he doesn't even realize
what's going on he's just there to
collect a paycheck
and this is yet another example of homer
giving up her dream job for his family
he
loves working for scorpio because it's
just a great gig he doesn't know about
the bond stuff
he's just very happy in cypress creek
but the rest of the family isn't
he gives up the job it's again it comes
down to his happiness versus his
family's happiness and they
they go back to springfield and because
homer actually succeeds in helping
scorpio build a doomsday machine
and take over the east coast he's
rewarded with his dream job which was to
be a owner of a football team
it's not the dallas cowboys but it's a
start
drop me a line if you're on the east
coast hank scorpio
unfortunately the football team turns
out to be the denver broncos
which at the time was not a very good
get
homer's genetically abnormal skull
allows him to take a lot of severe head
trauma so
moe puts him in the boxing ring and he
becomes this great boxer
at least until he has to go against the
champ dredrick tatum
who pretty much nearly kills in one blow
and this is one of those jobs where
it's not homer giving it up because his
family's unhappy he's giving it up
because it's literally going to kill him
it automatically calls them one by one
and plays my message
this is one of those get rich quick
schemes for homer he finds this
auto dialer and uses it to his advantage
by calling every phone number in
springfield and asking for a one dollar
happy dude i don't get to be a cartoon
dog
homer becomes a voice over actor for the
itchy and scratchy show playing poochy
the new hip
90s dog which everybody immediately
hates hey
kids always recycle
do the extreme this is the first acting
gig that homer gets and we're going to
see him get a bunch more
even in the voice over our field but
homer in addition to having a knack for
inventing and a knack for music
apparently homer's also really good at
acting well not that good because they
they immediately want to kill poochie
off
[Music]
homer takes advantage of springfield's
prohibition by becoming its chief
bootlegger he becomes known as the beer
baron
and he supplies the town with illegal
booze we've seen homer smuggle some
things before but this is the most
illegal thing he's done by far
he's basically the chief bootlegger in a
town he even becomes a target of
rex banner who's springfield's elliot
ness you're out there somewhere beer
baron
and i'll find you
join the family this is where the show
really starts to experiment and get meta
in this case we get three vignettes
possible spin-offs that the show can do
and one of them is a variety style show
where the simpsons play
themselves but entertainer versions of
themselves basically the simpsons and
quotes and it's not the last time
they're gonna do this
this is one of the first times the show
is actually acknowledged that it is a
show
and it really is quite meta they get
away with it again because
now after eight seasons they've done
such a good job
drawing and writing their characters and
writing the town of springfield that
we are so familiar with these characters
that they can now play with them
and they were already doing this a bit
with the treehouse of horror halloween
episodes but this is a very very meta
take
where the show is a show but the
characters are playing themselves
and it's a very fine line because an
audience could get lost but the writers
were counting
on the fact that the simpsons by now is
just a part of americana and they can
kind of take place
almost in our world
homer replaces flanders as the coach for
bart's team after heckling him from the
stands
what blenders
it's almost surprising it took nine
seasons but homer finally becomes a
carny working at a carnival
i got a few complaints that your game is
crooked
and uh homer's working unpaid here as a
member of a cult
but it's a lot of actual laborers
working in the fields and other menial
jobs for the cult so this
certainly counts as a job while most of
the jobs we've covered uh
is the show taking its aim at slices
of americana and american culture this
is them going after something a little
bit more specific they're basically
using
the power of satire to take down
scientology
homer sets up his own small business in
which he gives himself the title of
junior vice president
and this episode is really a great look
at what america's view
of this internet thing was in the late
90s
welcome to the internet my friend how
can i help you i'm interested in
upgrading my 28.8 kilowatt internet
connection to a 1.5 megabit fiber optic
t1 line
will you be able to provide an ip router
that's compatible with my token ring
ethernet lan configuration
while this might seem like ancient
history this is actually taking place in
the height of the
dot-com boom in the late 90s this is
where people like me were just
finding out what internet even was we
knew it would have something to do with
computers but we didn't know what it was
and we've come a long way since then uh
you're watching this on a computer or a
smart tv
i'm recording it on a phone which is
insane also this story is very
much of its time because it takes place
during the dot-com boom and like the
simpsons often does it kind of predicted
both the bust
and the corporate takeovers of smaller
companies when bill gates takes over the
competition
homer becomes a navy reservist and
serves on a submarine and eventually
becomes its captain
people's lives are depending on me mr
sulu
make a left aye aye captain setting
course for rigel seven
i mean home this is the first time we
actually see
homer in the line of duty and of course
it's just a simple war games exercise
that he nearly starts world war three
they want you to spy on your friends
after cheating on his taxes homer is
actually recruited by the fbi to be an
informant to rat out mr burns and this
is not the last time this is gonna
happen
homer runs for and wins the job of
springfield sanitation commissioner
aren't you gonna buy it dad 50 cents not
likely
in this capacity homer actually blows
the budget of the department so badly
that the entire town needs to relocate
several miles away from its own trash
homer is sponsored by power sauce to
climb springfield's tallest mountain
the murder horn grease collector this is
another get-rich-quick scheme by homer
where basically he goes around town with
bart collecting grease to sell it
that comes to 63 cents
[Music]
we've seen glimpses of this before but
this is where homer really shines as an
inventor he has a passion for just
building
and creating things and in this episode
thomas edison becomes his role model
and homer strives to be the next great
american inventor
close your eyes marge and now you're
ready for a night on the town
oh tell me over breakfast who's for
pancakes homer becomes a personal
assistant and this episode
is the simpsons at its best lampooning
hollywood culture
well you got everything homer even the
oscar polish
this job ends as so many of ours do by
nearly killing ron howard
season 10 is a very pivotal time for the
simpsons it's where the show is no
longer this upstart counter-cultural
thing but it is the culture the simpsons
is
hollywood culture and its relationship
to celebrities change they're now
not just doing voice-overs they're
playing themselves and kind of the
simpsons the show and the simpsons the
family
have literally become friends with the
celebrities
[Music]
very often when we do these homer gets
another job episodes
there's a lot of jokes based on homer
using his newfound set of skills
outside of the job in everyday life so
there's some great moments here where
homer learns a neck pinch that will make
you pass out and
he uses it so that he can pass out so he
doesn't have to wait for dinner
homer starts and ends his job the same
way protecting mark hamill
[Music]
homer starts a war with the trucking
industry when he becomes a trucker
himself and discovers their secret plot
self-driving trucks you stumbled on the
secret that only truck drivers are
supposed to know
this is one of those cases where the
show uh seems to predict the future with
an eerie sense of accuracy when this
came out a lot of people thought it was
a jump the shark moment because the idea
of trucks driving themselves across the
country was completely ridiculous
and now it may very well be the future
homer becomes a railroad engineer
presumably at the end of the episode
when he and bart are stranded anita way
back to springfield and it's implied
that they end up taking a train full of
napalm back to town
homer's rage actually leads to him
becoming an outsider artist
his masterpiece flood springfield and
turn it to the next
venice not vandalism
that's for the courts to decide son
hello little girl this is another
get-rich-quick scheme for homer
basically he comes into a bunch of
springs and needs to get rid of them and
when he designs this olympic mascot made
out of the springs
it shows both homer's latent inventing
and artistic skills that we see across
the board with a bunch of jobs
when the family gets stranded in japan
homer and the rest of the simpsons have
to work at a fish gutting factory
homer's hired by mel gibson to rework
his film and this is the first of
several times homer is going to be
working
on hollywood films the other critics
told me to be mean and you should always
give in to peer pressure
this job utilizes homer's love of food
something that has been well established
by this season
homer becomes a farmer and when he does
a poor job he improvises and uses
plutonium and ends up creating
a tomato a tomato tobacco hybrid that
because of its addictive qualities sells
very well
[Music]
on the run from the mob homer becomes a
missionary in the south pacific
you two haven't said a word i like that
you're hired homer's on the run from a
florida sheriff
and uh gets a job as a short-order cook
in this off-road diner
you might notice now the jobs are less
second jobs for extra income and more
jobs out of necessity uh either because
he's on the run
or being run out of town a lot of these
jobs homer really
doesn't need or is set up by ridiculous
circumstances
my funny family take one this is the
meta of all meta episodes this is where
the simpsons really do play quote
unquote the simpsons they're themselves
they're a family that lives in 742
evergreen terrace but they're also a
very famous american tv show
in this episode homer writes directs and
stars in
the simpsons that is watched by millions
across america
homer and i had real chemistry on screen
every day i thought about firing marge
you know
just to shake things up this is the
season finale for season 11. and in 11
seasons we've now seen the show
start as this grounded blue collar show
about a family and
literally becoming this meta show within
a show within a show
they're breaking the fourth wall they're
breaking the fifth wall at this point it
is more like a tesseract of walls and
they're smashing every single one of
them
loyal citizens of new springfield
when springfield is split into two towns
by area code homer actually becomes
mayor of new springfield
let's see how old snub field does
without
[Music]
electricity
mr burns pays homer to become his prank
monkey basically going around town
humiliating himself or pulling pranks on
other people specifically
just for mr burns amusement and this is
one of the first jobs we've seen
that is a completely made-up job we're
in season 12 now
homer needs to do something so why not
have him throw pudding in lenny's eye
my eye i'm not supposed to get pudding
in it i'll just call myself
mr x alright this might seem crazy but
back when this episode aired there
wasn't that many online conspiracy
theorists homer was one of the first as
mr x
this precursor to online flat earthers
and other conspiracy theorists homer
basically becomes famous
online by making these ridiculous
outlanders conspiracy theories
until he's detained by a mysterious
organization because one of them turns
out to be true
homer and bart become grifters counting
people around town out of money until
the town teaches them a lesson this is
around the time where homer
takes on these personalities a lot of
people call jerk ass homer
he's literally taking hard-earned money
out of other people's pockets
we start to see this more and more often
as the show reaches these uh seasons in
the teens and twenties
who's gonna buy a pill that makes you
blind barney gumbel suggests that homer
gets a job at a medical testing center
to earn a quick buck
it's there that the discover homer
actually lodged a crayon into his brain
when he was young
when they remove the crayon homer
becomes brilliant i was working on a
flat tax proposal
and i accidentally proved there's no god
we'll just see about that uh-oh
homer then gives a guest lecture at
springfield elementary on not putting
things up your nose
homer starts operating a chiropractor's
office out of his own garage
after a trash can he damaged seems to
miraculously fix people's backs
this one's one of those b stories that
kind of just exists to fill some pages
and it ends as quickly as it begins
where the real chiropractors take homer
out
homer creates his own baby proofing
industry when he realizes he'll save a
lot of money by doing it himself
and he becomes so good at his job coming
up with ways to
protect young children that he actually
affects the pediatrics industry
the dream is over just a few episodes
later stuck at home with a torn acl
homer creates uncle homer's daycare
center where he babysits
his friends and other people around
town's children
i'd like to speak to a mr to booger
first name ollie
oh bart my first prank call what do i do
just
homer first fills in for mo at moe's
tavern i don't get it and then when mo
rebrands as a swanky nightclub homer
opens up his own bar in the garage
at this point in the show's evolution
you can even start to see the writing
and the style of the show change
and the episodes become less character
based and less morality plays
and more plot devices and basically just
factories for jokes and gags and that
includes homer's jobs
a lot of homer's jobs fill the role of
just quick b plots
or one-off gags or just time fillers for
a laugh
so it you'll actually start to notice
that the jobs are less important for the
story
and uh you can almost just rattle them
off like you would a joke
you will take a short sea voyage
yeah i'll enjoy that after complaining
their fortunes in the fortune cookies
are unimaginative homer's actually hired
by a restaurant to write their fortunes
this episode kind of combines when homer
was selling sugar
and the one where he's smuggling and
bootlegging alcohol when springfield
puts a ban on sugar
homer actually starts to smuggle sugar
into town
[Music]
believing marge has left him for his old
rival artie ziff
homer runs away and gets a new job as an
oil rigger in west springfield
homer is promoted by mr burns to vice
president basically because he just
laughs at all of his
jokes working hard or hardly working
what burns doesn't know is homer is
completely stoned on medical marijuana
homer is sentenced to community service
and is forced to become a meals on
wheels driver
meals on wheels eat it up or i go to
jail
one of his meals on wheels clients
actually guilts him and marge into
becoming her servants
during a crime wave homer creates spring
shield a private security firm
i hereby turn over all this town's
police duties to homer simpson
and spring shields the mayor then
promotes him to chief of police where he
replaces wiggum
up until the mob almost kills him
you test in another celebrity guest star
heavy episode
homer becomes a roadie for several
iconic rock stars when they do a benefit
concert
[Music]
homer greased this gig to help pay off
bart and it's kind of perfect for him
because if you remember
he and his dad were actually selling
their own homemade viagra years before
the real product was on the market
it gives you lots of hair and what you
need down there
after finding out that technically a
canary is the ceo of the power plant
homer blackmails mr burns into giving
him the job now i need to find a patsy
hello you're quite the friendly fellow
but
right now i'm looking for a petsy hello
when he becomes his own boss and becomes
a ceo
he spends less time with his family and
when he finds himself missing them
he actually gives the job up this goes
back to old school homer where homer
will choose his family over his job and
while a lot of the episodes
at this point in the show get very wacky
and off base every once in a while the
show will remind us who the original
homer simpson is and they'll show us
the old grounded homer who will always
put his family first
i'd like to see his house go up in
flames
writes a song with david byrne called
everybody hates ned flanders that
becomes wildly popular this episode once
again shows homer has this innate
ability to write pop songs he writes
hits
if you just might like the pandas then i
doubt you'll like dead flanders
homer quite literally becomes death and
starts reaping souls around springfield
and when god asks him to kill marge this
is when he puts his foot down and quits
after homer does such a good job
replacing krusty on the sabbath
he's given his own talk show and becomes
very popular lisa then convinces him to
use his power for good and talk about
social issues
which quickly of course makes him lose
all his ratings this show stinks now you
might notice this isn't the first time
homer has
literally replaced krusty and that
actually has its origins
way back in the beginning of the show if
you notice krusty looks exactly like
homer with just a few changes of color
and hair and nose
and that is because matt greening's
original intent was for crest of the
clown to secretly be homer's alter ego
the joke being that bart's idol was
actually his father
much like the mr plow storyline homer
crashes his car and needs to buy a new
one and in this case he buys a 1950s
style ambulance
and since he has it he just becomes a
paramedic it's that easy homer actually
becomes a car
salesman first he needs the job after he
gets fired let's get out of here i'm not
shaking that guy's hand
i'll be back
and it's there that he buys the
ambulance basically from himself i think
this guy's coming on to me
poor jack horror actually wins artie
ziff's company while they're playing
poker but this was all part of artie's
plan
because the sec was actually after him
so when homer becomes ceo
homer gets arrested for securities fraud
[Music]
when bart goes to juvenile hall homer
actually gets a job as a guard so that
he can keep a better eye on him and
protect them
of course this just makes bart a bigger
target
superhero this episode aired right at
the dawn of the superhero trend in
hollywood it's a big blockbuster
superhero movies and this one takes his
cues from spider-man homer becomes pie
man
where he throws pies in people's faces
and they even recreate the iconic upside
down kiss with marge
prescription drug smuggler homer
smuggles prescription drugs from canada
after mr burns and other town employers
take away everybody's health insurance
this is the first time in a while we've
seen homer take on a job
that harkens way back to the beginning
when he was uh looking out for the
greater good and the good of his fellow
man
which describes you sir homer becomes a
professional victory dance choreographer
here
for celebrities including tom brady and
michelle kwan and he's actually asked to
do the super bowl half time show
at last my pathetic little life has a
meaning
you suckers i would have done it for
free fine do it for free
damn it he doesn't really know what to
do so he teams up with ned and makes a
christian themed show
which immediately gets booed by
everybody
ordained minister when reverend lovejoy
refuses to marry a same-sex couple homer
seizes the opportunity and gets ordained
from the online
episcopal church charging gay couples
to marry them this episode once again
shows how the simpsons is always a
reflection of current attitudes in
america
so in season eight there's an episode
called homer's phobia
where homer is uh homophobic homer what
have you got against gays
you know it's it's not usual here it
shows not just how far homer has come
but how far america has come
in terms of accepting lgbtq plus couples
welcome to
walmart nipple cream straw mark greeter
so homer defending the rights of his
fellow
underpaid greeters it shows again homer
is kind of a working-class hero
homer would you be interested in the
position of executive greeter
that's been my dream ever since i heard
it existed right now
what do i get get to work overtime
without us paying you extra
i won't do it if you don't we'll ship
you right back to mexico
the simpsons index coined the term
parallel import for when the show
decides to use their own knockoff brand
rather than mention a real company or
product so this use of parallel imports
the reason i want to mention it is
because it's very common throughout the
show especially in the later seasons
why they do it is it because it's just
they have a lot of fun writing stupid
puns
they want to avoid lawsuits one good
reason is they probably can use
a fictional company a fictional name to
represent not just a specific company
but
larger societal ills
homer pretends to be his sister-in-law
selma's husband to help her adopt a
child in china
and as part of the ruse homer says he's
an acrobat when they put him to the test
he actually has to go on stage and
perform acrobatics
[Music]
[Applause]
homer becomes a composer and manager for
lisa as she competes
on little star maker which is the show's
parallel import of american idol he then
becomes the manager for her rival
cameron who he rebrands as johnny
rainbow
homer becomes a competitive arm wrestler
when he faces opponents such as
lefty the righty left right look folks
it's season 17
homer's gonna arm wrestle it's just it's
it's where we are now tip 99
safety salamander homer becomes a
costume mascot that teaches children to
avoid downed power lines
which is a very important lesson to
learn after rescuing people from a car
accident in his salamander costume homer
has pushed
a run against mayor quimby in a recall
election remember he was once mayor of
new springfield
he's also mayor quimby's bodyguard so
he's danced around this position before
but he's never quite
run for mayor he actually loses the
election when people see him out of
costume though
at this point in the show we're in
season 17 the country itself
has become much more polarized it
resembles where we are now with the
right versus the left
even though the show has always touched
on politics and homer's always kind of
been an outsider and never really a
specific republican or democrat
you'll start to see the show itself
become a little bit more political
just because it's representing a country
that has become more political
so it's interesting to see this is where
homer runs for mayor this is really
where
we start going from general to specifics
at least when it comes to politics
human advertisement homer starts wearing
advertisements on his physical body
to help sell blue pants for the company
that makes his pants
basically so that they can stay in
business and keep making the pantsy
likes
this is probably a specific reference to
around this time there was a kid walking
around college with advertisements
tattooed on his face
and the show was always quick to point
out kind of weird crazy things like that
homer becomes manager of the power plant
when it's outsourced to india
when homer treats his employees well
burns is infuriated and moves the plant
back to springfield
this is another one of those issue
episodes where the simpsons writers take
on outsourcing
yellow dad i gotta write a report on the
great lakes just outsource it to lisa
outsourcing is the answer to everything
homer please
marriage counselor a famous baseball
player and his pop star wife
asked homer and marge to be their
marriage counselors well
i think we really hit on something here
unfortunately we're out of time
this probably isn't the best idea
because homer's done this before the
adult education addicts and it nearly
cost him his marriage
and that was part one of each and every
job homer has had on the simpsons
we've got a lot more so please stick
around and stay tuned for part two